I miss you on the view is there any way
we'll ever see you back on the panel and
what would it take no Jerry Shepherd
shutting down a return to the daytime
talker that made her a household name on
the set of her new Netflix series mr.
Iglesias the view was one of the best
experiences of my life being close to
Barbara Walters and Whoopi Goldberg my
idol and it was it was the best eight
years but you know it's like going back
to an old boyfriend and sleeping with
him again then you look up and you go
how did we get here I love it I love to
go back and guest co-host but it's for
it's for now for Meghan McCain and Abby
Huntsman sunny Hostin Joy Behar and
Whoopi Goldberg it's theirs now I've had
a great time and I left it with love and
everyone who loves you can now watch you
the 51 year old left the daytime show in
2014 at the time a rep for Shepherd said
in a statement to ET quote it's been
seven wonderful years on the view and
after careful consideration it is time
for me to move on I am incredibly
grateful to my view family and my fans
for supporting me on this journey
she later tweeted quote life should be
lived run towards the things that scare
you choose joy and trust God everything
else will work out as it should when et
sat down with the former co-host in 2016
she revealed what she learned from her
time on the show I love being a
full-time host for the seven years that
I was on there Barbara Walters gave me
an amazing platform and I learned so
much when people say to me you're always
on time I go because I work for Barbara
Walters for seven years you should try
it but it's you know it's time to move
on everything has an end and when it's
time to get off the ride you want to get
off with a smile so it was the best
seven years when somebody's sick if I'm
in town I fill in for them but you know
I get to go and do what I'm doing right
now which is acting
you